Last time on The Wokking Dead,
Chef Brian and I battled it out to see who could make the best Bloody Sundaes.
Now a random stranger will decide my fate on the show.
BRIAN: And the future of my self-published cookbook.
BRIAN: Here comes a random stranger walking up now.
CORDON: Whoa! Ozzy Osbourne!
That really is random!
Want to try an ice cream sundae?
OZZY: Sure, why not?
BRIAN: OK, now try mine.
OZZY: Well, this is no Blizzard of Oz.
CORDON: OK... So whose did you like better?
OZZY: Oh, easy. I think Chef Brian's is better.
CORDON: What!?!
BRIAN: Sorry Cordon, looks like you're off the show.
No hard feelings, put her there.
CORDON: AHH!!!
*screams of agony*
OZZY: Oh my God! HAHAHAHA!
BRIAN: It's so painful!
It hurts so much!
BRIAN: Why Cordon? WHY?!
*screams of agony*
BRIAN: Put me out of my misery; I can't take this excruciating pain any longer! Why!
Oh this is horrible.
CORDON: You're a cool guy Ozzy.
Sign my boob.
DAVE: Chef Brian! What happened?
BRIAN: Cordon challenged me, just like you said he would.
BRIAN: And I made a Sundae, and Ozzy came up, just like we planned.
BRIAN: But then Cordon attacked me! Please just stop the pain!
DAVE: Cordon!
DAVE: You! There's a zombie outbreak antidote in the fridge. Hurry!
CORDON: Oh Dave! You won't find any antidote in the fridge!
I took care of that a long time ago.
DAVE: Cordon, you really did it this time!
DAVE: But did you really have to drag Chef Brian into this?
CORDON: Yes.
BRIAN: Tell my--
BRIAN: Tell my wife and kids I love them.
BRIAN: And my dog...
BRIAN: Blondie.
CORDON: You won't be telling anyone anything!
DAVE: What are you talking about?
CORDON: Remember that fish you had last night with your girlfriend?
CORDON: That's a little recipe I call Radioactive a la Carte!
CZsWorld is definitely not responsible if you die from eating that one,
because I guarantee, YOU WILL! Haha!
DAVE: You can only push me and push me so far before I snap!
DAVE: Cordon Gruesome...
DAVE: Prepare to meet your final course!
♫ WE ARE THE WOKKING DEAD! ♫
♫ THE WOKKING DEAD! ♫
♫ WE ARE THE WOKKING DEEEAAADDD!!! ♫
Welcome to the season finale of The Wokking Dead.
This one comes from a user named Legitimate Lemonade.
He or she writes:
Well... stupid Lemonade name,
it has nothing to do with Dave's hat.
But I still have a perfect human recipe to demonstrate.
And it'll be great of all grilling occasions,
including Zombie Independence Day, Kill All Humans Day...
and Labor Day.
For this recipe you'll need:
salt, pepper, onion powder, garlic powder, dead human, ground coriander and red pepper flakes.
While we wait for Dave to pass, I'm gonna demonstrate with ground beef, corn and ribs
in place of the dead human.
I knew I should have added a pinch of cyanide to his fish...
Start by adding seasoning to everything.
For the beef, you'll want to form it into a skull shape.
Get it in there nice and tight.
I bought this for $5 online because he looks like me.
But anyways, you pack the beef in there
and it makes it taste and feel like a real human brain.
*knocking on door*
What is that?
DAVE: Cordon, you open up this school right now or so help me!
CORDON: Nobody open the door!
*banging on door*
DAVE: I will bang this door down!
*knock knock knock*
*body hits door*
DAVE: Ahh!
CORDON: Anyways...
We need to wrap the corn in tin foil.
Get in there. Yep.
Goodnight little buddy.
Tuck you in. I'll sing you a lullaby later.
*approaching sirens*
Ah OK.
To carry all this stuff, you'll need a tray.
But I like to use...
a wok!
DAVE: You're in for it now, you obnoxious zombie slime!
CORDON: Whoa Dave! No need to pull the race card.
*controlled explosion*
FDA: FDA Motherfuckers, put your Goddamn hands where I can see 'em!
CORDON: Oh!
CORDON: What is this?
FDA: I've got reports of you eating baby brains, radioactive foods and a whole lot of other shit you dead fuck!
Are you Cordon Gruesome?
CORDON: No...
That's Cordon Gruesome!
DAVE: He's lying, get him!
FDA: Boys, book him!
*thud*
*knock knock knock*
FDA GENERAL: Freeze Gruesome!
I got the shot all lined up so don't try anything!
CHRIS: You ain't got shit!
CORDON: Chris!
CORDON: Welcome to the show buddy!
CHRIS: What up Cordon?
CORDON: Glad you made it.
CHRIS: Always and forever man.
CORDON: Alright Chris. Your job for the next two human hours is to guard this grill with your life.
Because thats how long this takes to cook these ribs at 375°F.
CHRIS: Alright, sounds easy.
DAVE: AHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHH!!!!!!!!!!!!!!
CORDON: The meat loaf can be cooked for 45 minutes,
until it hits an internal temperature of 160°F.
CORDON: And the corn can cook for 20 minutes,
and you can rotate it slowly...
if you're not being shot at.
DAVE: This is for 5 episodes of abuse.
ZOMBIE BRIAN: Auuuugghhhhhh....
CORDON: Chef Brian?
ZOMBIE BRIAN: Braaaiiiinnnssss!
CHRIS: No, don't eat me, eat him!
CORDON: They always start off like that.
FDA: Agh!
Incidentally, grilling forks are a great tool for impaling humans.
Well, this brings us to the end of The Wokking Dead.
We've cooked up 6 of the most delicious recipes known to man.
Or Zombie.
And somehow, Dave and I didn't kill each other.
CORDON AND CHRIS: Oh shit...
CORDON: Well, anyways.
I hope you had as much fun as I did.
Remember, like and subscribe and do this in your own kitchen,
on your own grill,
IN YOUR OWN HOME!
Or wherever you live...
*massive explosion*
Your chef, Cordon Gruesome, signing off.
Coming up on the 10 o'clock news,
the new phenomenon that all the kids are calling: "roadhead".
But first, the story of how the FDA opened fire on celebrity chef Cordon Gruesome.
Sources say that he was filming an episode of his show The Wokking Dead when the incident occured.
Hundreds are presumed dead.
Gruesome's whereabouts are still unknown.